norm Peterson was one of the regular
patrons on cheers but where did George
went the actor who played him go after
the bar closed up we've got the details
right here while cheers was still on the
air went began appearing in a series of
sketches on Saturday Night Live as Bob
sworsky a die-hard Chicago sports fan
and host of the show bill Swersky
superfans went is a Chicago native
himself and is a lifelong supporter of
all Windy City sports teams he was
instantly relatable to any other local
fans who were watching the sketches
originally aired in the early 90s
shortly before cheers ended in 1993 but
that wasn't the end of Bob sworsky or
his passionate commentary on Chicago
sports went his return to SNL to play
sworsky several times with a total of
nine appearances between 1991 and 2003
he's also shown up in character as Bob
outside of SNL in 2019 for example he
stopped by the ESPN Plus Series Payton's
places in which peyton manning meets
with a variety of interesting figures to
explore the history of football and the
cultural impact of the sports baby
Payton my son are you ready to be
baptized into the Bears super fandom
well I'm not drunk so no a couple years
after Cheers ended wines got his own
starring sitcom game alas the George
Wendt show reached nowhere near the
success of cheers airing for only one
season on CBS in 1995 perhaps a sitcom
actually based around norm Peterson whom
the audience already knew and loved
would have been a better move it took a
few years after the George Wendt show
wrapped / went to nab another regular TV
gig in 1997 he appeared on the sitcom
the naked truth for three episodes then
in 2001 he appeared on another comedy
show but this time it was a series with
a different kind of audience and he was
used to as he checked in for six
episodes of Sabrina the Teenage Witch
and in 2006 he was on the one season WB
sitcom modern men as a guy who dished
out dating advice to confuse single men
even though he'd been through a few
divorces himself none of the shows that
went worked on after leaving Boston
really got the same reception that
Cheers did but of course that's the type
of iconic show that doesn't come around
very often and went knows it well
reflected on the show's enduring
popularity he told the Toronto Sun in
2017 it's such a pleasant surprise
that's something you were a part of
make such an impact besides cheers
whence longest-running TV gig in terms
of episode counts was on the TBS sitcom
flipped
he played buzzy a guy who used to own a
barber shop named naturally enough
fuzzies in the show he still works there
but now the place is owned and managed
by a fellow named Ben back in the day
Ben was an unpopular kid in high school
but now that he's the boss at Buzzy's
he's in charge of a few of his old
classmates naturally jealousy and penny
antics ensue as for buzzy he might be
beyond all that high school drama but
he's got relationship problems of his
own like figuring out how to propose to
the man of his dreams the show ran for
10 episodes in the summer of 2015 and
was officially canceled a few months
after the last episode aired on Cheers
George Wendt starred alongside some
pretty impressive names in the world of
comedy but recently he started working
with someone even more important to him
his wife
Bernadette Burkett the couple starred
together in a 2013 production of the
comedy play never too late the original
version of this show was popular on
Broadway in the 1960s but it's not a
very well-known play today however went
and Burkett's version was well received
and positively reviewed in the play went
played Harry Lambert's a successful and
traditionally minded man who owns a
Lumber Company and thinks that his wife
Edith truly enjoys waiting on him hand
and foot
but when Edith comes home with the news
that she's pregnant Harry is totally
caught off guard went in Burkett were
praised for bringing their real-life
chemistry to the stage Robert Russell of
the Kansas City Star noted the bombastic
Harry is the show where your role but
Burkett goes for relatively subtle humor
and a precise thoughtful performance for
his part when delivers a master class on
comedic timing although most of Wentz
acting work has been on TV he's had
plenty of film credits to his name as
well his career started with bit parts
in movies and he appeared in a couple of
films that you probably enjoyed as a kid
in 1994 for example he had a memorable
supporting role as a lumber yard clerk
in The Little Rascals and of course we
can't forget spiceworld in which he
played one of the guys pitching film
ideas for the girls to star in 20 cent
film credits include the 2017 Adam
Sandler Netflix vehicle sandy Wexler and
the comedy decline which screened at the
2019 can Film Festival he's also got
multiple projects in post-production and
maybe one day we'll see the return of
norm and the rest of the gang on the big
screen when the Toronto Star asked him
in 2017 about the
ability of a Cheers reboot he said I
think some sort of reboot is inevitable
whether it's a movie or a show
alas he also added but I wouldn't hold
my breath check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff or
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]